another year comes to a close and once
again is time for my top 10 favorite
movies of a year this year 2015 I love
my top 10 list so I'm gonna get right
into this but first of all we use the
preliminaries some ground rules here
between us first of all I have not seen
every movie that has come out in 2015 I
know this this happens every year every
year there are movies I just I don't see
it's okay the world is kept spinning
every year I've done this which is about
half a decade it will continue to spin
this next year because of it I also know
and accept that I have seen every movie
I'm going to see in 2015 so there is
very little reason to postpone this
video any longer and every year there is
that one movie that gets a limited
release in December and they gets a
wider release in January and I don't get
to see it until January after I do my
top 10 favorite movies of that year this
year it's the revenant I don't know if
the revenant would make my top 10 list I
haven't seen it I'm not psychic but so
happens I won't see it until January
sorry about that I really want to see
the rabbit but of the movies I have seen
this year these are my 10 faves and
remember this is my very subjective top
10 list these are not reviews of the
movies in fact the movies on this list
they might not have the best acting they
might not have the most solid script
they might not have the best
cinematography I don't need it in order
to be my favorites this is my list this
is what touched me and here is what hit
me where I live for those of you who are
here to have fun with the top 10 list
let's talk about my top 10 favorite
movies of 2015 number 10 starting off
this list is bridge of spies I
ultimately roles a three sided dice for
number 10 I do that every year it's like
these these movies could all be number
10 but in this one I'm doing bridge of
spies bridge of spies were just an
intriguing movie I love the Cold War era
I love the conflict I love the strife I
love how those shots were fired who's
just all espionage and information and
Steven Spielberg showed us he still got
it he can direct tension he can make us
root for a normal guy who shouldn't be
in that situation who was the perfect
guy to negotiate that situation number 9
coming up next ex machina this is one of
those movies like I said my review is
like the more I thought about it the
more I liked it this is an intriguing
movie ultimately three characters in the
entire movie the performances in this
movie alone blew my mind Oscar Isaac in
this movie I was like I will probably
like you in everything your only
you're in a Star Wars movie you thought
he was great in Star Wars the
a different kind of great next machina
but still great it's a movie about
humanity telling it with artificial
intelligence and it reminded me of my
favorite episode of The Twilight Zone
ever I'll tell you here I didn't tell
you my review I didn't want to spoil it
but it's the howling man once I made
that connection it was almost doomed to
be on my top ten list number eight
coming up next was the surprise of the
summer for me Straight Outta Compton
this movie was an interesting biopic
knock in a line the neighborhood I grew
up in they were the ones stomping on the
NWA CDs it was really fascinating for me
to see a fictionalized version of what
happened from the other side of the
fence I enjoyed it I was intrigued I was
hooked I loved the music I'm not gonna
lie to you I bought the NWA CD it's in
my car right now I listened to it quite
often number seven
next one on our list James Bond got a
facelift for a new generation Kingsman
the Secret Service this was the most fun
I've had in a spy movie that knew it was
a ridiculous spy movie a movie very
rarely knows exactly what it is this
movie knew it was James Bond for a new
generation it had cool gadgets it had
kick-ass we add a ridiculous bad guy who
ate McDonald's the church shoot up scene
alone in Kingsman probably it gave it a
place in my top 10 list the last shot in
this movie is admittedly a bit awkward
but who cares Reza movie so kick-ass
number six next one on our list you all
know what it is the original came out in
the 70s it captured everyone's heart now
a new chapter comes out in 2015
uses most of the notes from the original
if not making it a complete retelling of
the original but we all love it anyway
that's right it's great did you think I
was gonna say star wars Creed was an
extension of the rocky universe done in
the perfect way it had kick-ass fights
and had great characters it integrated
Sylvester Stallone perfectly with this
story and got one of the best
performances out of him we've seen in a
long time in terms of the rocky universe
this is right up there with the original
rocky itself
number five next on the list Quentin
Tarantino's the hateful eight again like
ex machina after I saw the movie I was
like the more I think about this the
more I just love this out of it
it's almost a cheat when Tarantino comes
out with a new movie I'm like it's
probably going to be on my list the guy
just captivates us with dialog in this
case he has given us a mystery a mystery
that is probably better the second time
you watch it I haven't seen it a second
time yet but I really want to I will say
the hateful eight gave me the most
unique cinematic experience of 2015 and
that it's really hard to place it
somewhere on this list to say it's
better because of this or not as good as
the other movies because of that I wish
more movies gave you the experience that
the hateful eight gave me but I'm glad
they don't because that makes the
hateful eight a little more special
pretty solid batting average for
Tarantino at this point war now this
movie is a movie I guess some people
thought I hated Mad Max fury road I'm
not even lying to you guys I met a fan
at Paxton he was like I got a bone to
pick with you man how come you didn't
like Mad Max fury road it was like what
yeah really weird I guess like when I
said I'd buy Mad Max fury road on
blu-ray it meant hey I only buy shitty
movies no not the case I buy movies that
are pretty cool Mad Max fury
road is one of those movies Mad Max fury
road was exciting it was fun it was like
what the movie doesn't stop it is a
kick-ass cool ass movie that showed us
that practical effects had guess what it
makes a movie better
and again like apparently most movies on
this list the more I watched it the more
I was like oh yeah it's great it's great
it's better another fun movie that knows
it's a fun kick-ass movie you can't ask
for more than that number three coming
in at number three was the best Pixar
movie I have seen in years that's inside
out for me inside out with just beard
genius someone's like it's just a movie
explaining puberty I was like yeah
that's you're telling me how cool the
movie is good sorry that's a genius
concept it has heart it has the feels it
has a great premise a unique premise I
laughed I cried
I saw the movie again I laughed more I
cried more no but - all right like usual
number two and number one I almost had
to flip a coin to see what went where
because I loved both for very different
reasons coming in at number two that's
the Martian unlike most movies I watch I
actually read the book before I saw the
movie because it just sounded like a
genius concept so I read the book and it
was a great book and then I saw the
movie and it was a great movie based on
a great book that I read this is an
updated version of the man versus nature
tale it was funny it was intense again
it was heartfelt
it is a
guy alone on Mars who is doomed to die
but he has to science the out of
that situation
to live a worthy fight for life if ever
there was one no whoa whoa
that's right don't blink and always
believe me when I say I am a fan of
movies first and I critique movies
second like I said subjective list
I am a fan star wars the force awakens
because no movie in 2015 gave me as much
fun with the build-up of a movie and has
given me this much fun after the release
of a movie my friends and I we talk star
wars we watch star wars I've seen this
movie a few times I like it more every
time I watch it I feel like most anybody
will enjoy star wars the force awakens
it just it's all a matter of how much
they left themselves this movie did
exactly what I wanted it to do it gave
Star Wars CPR for me if you love the
prequels fantastic but for me the saga
just needed something and this was the
something and for nothing else it is the
bridge I feel like people who love the
prequels can love this movie people who
love the original trilogy can love this
movie we could all play Star Wars
together certainly awoke the Star Wars
fan in me and that feeling in me just
embodies why I love movies and that's
why it's got to be my number one movie
of 2015 all right so that's my list
those are my top 10 favorite movies of
2015 like I said I know I haven't seen
them all but those are the ones I love
those are the ones that touched me those
are the ones that made me go yeah movies
another year down another fun year on
YouTube but what is your top 10 list
what are your top 10 favorite movies of
2015 whatever they are comment below let
me know do you agree with my list great
let me know do you not agree with my
list great let me know it's cool if you
disagree we're gonna be a dick bag about
it please go yourself you can
disagree without being a dick bag I'm
just saying we all want to have fun here
so don't be a however I hope you
had a great year of movies in 2015 I do
want to hear what your list is and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you